peppa pig is making headlines as the  long-running children's show has  introduced a character with same-sex  parents this is a first for the series  the storyline comes after years of  campaigning for the program to showcase  a more diverse selection of families a  petition to persuade the series creators  to make the change was launched two  years ago and gathered almost 24 000  signatures in the new episode titled  families penny polar bear draws a  picture of her family and explains she  has two mommies check it out and drop  your thoughts in the comments below  i'm penny polar bear i live with my  mommy and my other mummy one mommy is a  doctor and one mommy cooks spaghetti  i love spaghetti  lovely penny  oh this just warms my heart listen this  is the power of the audience wanting  this for so many years and also with  this being one of the most popular  children shows of all time this is a  step in the right direction